[Music]  Kim and Kourtney Kardashian make a  stylish pair so sheep check out 38 year  old Courtney in Los Angeles on Wednesday  flashing her lacy bra under a sheer  black turtleneck top tucked into a  miniskirt courts licked her hair back  and paired to look with me hi at black  boots really cute the mom of three was  joined by sister Kim who rocked a  matching Brown leggings and tank combo  with her platinum blonde hair down and  loose speech weights she added a pair of  strappy heels to the otherwise casual  look I want to wear things that make me  feel good about myself  keeping up with the Kardashian cameras  were rolling on the ladies they were  picking up some Christmas decorations at  all takes yeah we really have the best  time ever and we know the Kardashians  are already in the holiday spirit Kris  Jenner tees their annual Christmas card  photo shoots earlier this week I love  that  you